[Music]
top five is written and directed by
Chris Rock as well as starring him and
rosario Dawson it's a movie about a very
famous guy who's had a career he had
some well-known things that were kind of
a joke and everyone wants them to stay
that way but he's also had a serious
problem with alcohol addiction and now
he's being interviewed by rosario Dawson
who's a news reporter about his new
attempt at launching a serious career
now I've always thought the Chris Rock
was really funny his stand-up is genius
I mean the guy is hilarious but his
movie career was never that great I know
a lot of stand-up comedians have a
really hard time transitioning from live
performances to in a film because live
performances are filled with raw energy
you're able to control that so much you
write the whole thing then suddenly
you're in a movie
with a whole bunch of other people
trying to control you and that's a very
difficult transition for a lot of
stand-up comedians this is his third
film that he's directed and by far his
best
I found top five to be one of the
funniest movies of 2014 and had at least
two truly gut-busting li-like guffaw
worthy I'm the loudest person in the
theatre moments I thought it was funny
and heartfelt all the way through but
those moments are like the ones where
you just go holy crap I can't breathe
and this movie has at least a few of
them what I love about this movie is
that Chris Rock is so vulnerable in it
like he's usually such a comedian who's
such a ferociously just out there guy
like look at me I'm awesome but in this
movie you really do start to feel for
him and he shows an emotional side to
him that I've never seen in a film from
him ever and despite its really
hilarious moments it has a lot of really
touching heartfelt small human moments
especially between him and rosario
Dawson as they walk around the city and
he gets interviewed by her you learned
about her life you learned about his
life you get to see awesome areas of the
city but it's really just about these
small moments that you share with people
that can really be hilarious and stories
that you tell and ways of inspiring
yourself to be the way you want to be
well also being friggin gut-busting ly
funny there are tons of celebrity cameos
in this movie odds are if you're a fan
of comedy there's gonna be at least one
person in here that you love the movie
also explores Fame and celebrity quite a
bit
it's one of those movies where you have
a celebrity and he's walking down the
street and people are asking him for
autographs all the time
and he's talking about boohoo how
horrible my life is and it's so easy to
look at celebrities or famous people or
people who have any Fame and say I
understand you entirely I see you in a
video or I see you on Twitter or I see
you in a movie and I know you as a
person that's simply not true and this
movie explores that amazingly because
I've had experiences where I've been
told that I am a certain way because of
a video you know it's like no it's just
of my opinion on a movie it's not my
life and it's really easy to relate to
the film whether or not you're famous or
you're just a normal guy like me you're
able to watch the film and relate to the
fact that tons of people are always
trying to box you into whatever they
want you to be and it's crazy how in
depth top 5 actually got because I went
to the film thinking this could be
really funny because Chris Rock is
hilarious but I had heard a lot of
things about it and they were true this
movie is actually a lot more heartfelt
than you would expect but I need to
reiterate this movie was hilarious okay
I'm usually kind of a quiet laugher
where I'm like that was funny in this
movie they were moans I was like like
that was the crazy hilarious moments at
least two or three of them were I was
the loudest guy in the room which is
rare for me because I like my silence in
the movies but in a comedy sometimes you
just gotta let it out and top five had
truly hilarious moments really heartfelt
human moments interesting character
relationships tons of awesome comedian
cameos and a story that you actually do
start to care about it's not one of
those comedies where when it gets
serious it gets boring because that is
one of the biggest falls of comedies
where it starts out so funny and then
all of a sudden you got to have a
serious moment and it just goes for like
30 minutes straight where the movies
trying to make you cry top five story
was interesting enough that I cared
during the more serious moments I'm
gonna give top five a B+ it's by far
Chris Rock's best work in film and by
far the funniest thing he's done in
years what do you know top five was the
best movie out this weekend definitely
go check it out if you have a chance
guys oh really quick yeah something
really cool that you guys would be
interested in and something came across
my desk recently a giveaway for some TVs
from HH greg and LG an LG 55 inch curved
Oh
smart HDTV an LG 49 inch 4k HD Smart TV
or an LG 300 watt 2.1 Channel sound bar
every single hour on December 16th has
been given away I left the link in the
description below you guys can go and
enter that contest and also the youtuber
who has the most entries receives a free
television so if you go to the link that
I left in the description below and use
your special code which is my name Chris
you can enter that contest hopefully
receive a free TV so like I said these
prizes are being given away every hour
on the 16th of this month go to the link
in the description below and use that
special code Chris to sign up for that
and hopefully one of you guys will win
and if I win I'll surely let you know
and give you all a big hug and I can't
really do that but I'll thank you that's
for sure what do you know top five was
the best movie out this weekend I got a
question for you who's your favorite
comedian
as always guys thank you so much for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck man eyes
[Music]